hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to realm of the mad God now
this game that man my editor showed me
and it seemed obscenely cool but very
simplistic and you'll see what I mean in
just a second as I'm getting into
I barely started playing it just because
I was thinking I've already done the
tutorial thank you
I don't need it I'm very smart at games
so as you move through this world you'll
find that it wants you to buy stuff but
don't worry about that I'm not and
ignore all this this is not with main
games about so just let me let me let me
move out of here so that I can actually
hang out antler I haven't even set up my
controls correctly and Louise let me try
this hang on bear with me ah there we go
okay whoa hey well okay never mind then
god damnit they screwed me over damn it
damn it damn it well anyway this might
be a good time to introduce that it's a
roguelike game where you can die very
horribly in a lot of ways so I have to
play a new character now I like my will
I'll be a priest I'll be a breathe
Tigers okay so you create your class see
in the game it seems like a horrible
spam fest but that's because the game is
actually free so anyone can get into
this and it is a horrible spam fest but
that doesn't mean that it's too terribly
bad so let me try to get back to where I
was and then hopefully I won't die in an
instant like the idiot made me died do
okay so I'm here now where is here oh ow
oh my god now who dis head who did that
who thinks they can be as bad as me okay
oh so bad ah this time I'm gonna show
you what is up and it is what and what
is up is so cool oh oh oh oh oh
oh no no no no okay this time I got
control I am dead again I got killed by
a flying brain freak alack alack er well
this is not going as I planned it would
but you will see this game is fun in a
bit ah okay
so I seem to have a hold of things and
I'm not dying right away but I'm pretty
sure it's probably gonna happen very
soon
oh goodness look at him oh goodness look
at me I'm gonna Ted ah eventually I'm
gonna show you what this game is all
about but apparently I can't even get to
where I want to go and Matt failed to
show me anything else but doing this so
this is a No oh what a way well okay
alright well now we're with some pp
oh now with some peepees with some
people's that's adage in to type a genie
I suppose caught that whoopee
oh my gosh we did it we did it I'm with
a crew and we're hitting it all right
okay so this is where I was supposed to
show you is that in this particular
server now Matt said that this doesn't
happen in all the servers you can
actually play in a giant cluster with a
whole bunch of people and try to dodge
whatever you can and then if you stay in
a group together you will gain XP level
up and then win the game I think maybe I
don't know I really I don't know for
sure it's it's all a big I'm going to
die again yeah see the thing about it is
it's very simplistic but it's also very
heart attack II because it does have
rogue elements roguelike elements but
also there's something that carries over
to your next character every time you
play so there's a little bit of
progression to it and also it's just
giant minefield of horribleness that
everything's trying to kill you and it's
bad
bad news no not bad in bad games but bad
news for you if you're trying to do
anything so if you want a free game that
you can play with your friends whenever
you feel like it you can just pick this
up because it's totally free to play it
doesn't take much to create an account
I'm almost dead again and you do do a
thing cluster up cluster up everybody
you got to stay close to people before
you so that you can start gaining XP I'm
doing okay I'm doing alright here I'm
doing alright I'm doing okay either the
beholder I don't know what that is so I
haven't like I said I haven't douve did
a diamond
I haven't did load deep into the game
just yet and hopefully I'll level before
I die here
come on level before I die level before
I die oh god oh god oh yes oh yes oh
good golly gasps oh gasps oh yes oh yes
oh little too close for comfort there oh
yes oh yes I'm not doing any damage to
these guys I am of no help I am the
gasps I am of some help to myself and
that's all that matters
I'm still alive I'm still in this to win
this forever and a day my cluster
doesn't seem to be doing very good there
seems to be a lot of other better
clusters going on and every class has
its own unique ability some can heal
other people some can do things I have a
kind of an AoE explosion attack lots of
little doobie dues that you can do and
it's just fun because it's something
easy to pick up
now I'm not paid to promote this game in
any way this is something this Matt
showed me and told me that's why I say
ignore all the micro transactions don't
buy anything in this game there's no
reason to I'm blind I'm blind but
because it's got roguelike elements
there's a semblance of risk that the
more you build up your character just
that know that anytime you die it could
be permanent death and you'll never come
back from death poisoning and everything
will be horrible but if you got friends
if you want to play oh I see where the
cluster is uh oh hey whoa
whoa what I don't know what a pity but I
hope I'm hitting something good at it
yeah yeah that's it yeah ow owie owie
I'm pretty sure it's one of the
free-to-play games that you never need
to actually buy anything to progress you
just like you buy to progress faster is
what it probably is I'm out of murder
I'm out of mana you take my tiny
itty-bitty bolts haha I did some of that
okay I'm gonna go for the big cluster
over here uh uh uh oh I did wanna die
how did I shoot a thousand three hundred
and forty eight times again I'm only
showing you this game I don't know a lot
about it I'm going to be playing it a
lot more because I think it's really
cool okay yeah this is this got to be a
lower level area so when it's got
something like this it says a quest so I
have a quest to kill a scorpion king
queen and the scorpion Queen is up here
so if I actually wanted to play the game
and progress normally and not like an
idiot I would do this and not fall
face-first into the chaos of madness
that is this MMO but there is a lot of
charm to it even though there isn't a
lot of stuff to do and then you get
drops and these don't have anything that
I can actually use and I don't think I
can actually I don't know I might be
able to like sell them or something but
it's hard to Lewton gods at the same
time Baboosh Babu ski Naboo ski and you
can also pick what server you play on
visible what deserts okay I got a new
quest to kill the Bandit leader goony
Pony gumdrops he deserves to die
probably pret maybe I don't know high
level and he's big too I think like
everything else in human society their
hierarchy is ranked by bigness and how
large they are or girthy if you rather
would will you probably don't rather
would will that but it is the way that
it is in this work I'm gonna kill this
bunny a pair of cleave Oh God demon
buddy
Damon bunny on fire
okay all right okay all right okay all
right okay
all right calm down there calm down
there apparently you not you're not
heirarchy I used by bigness oh gosh
Olga Sh well goodness Kirsch I can't use
any of this what is this crap yeah your
bows do nothing to me I'm too Strang a
giant crab more like oh my god
huh stop shouting at me I didn't even
know crabs could shout bang dead okay I
still can't use these can I sell them
for months I need some mugs real bad
Hobbit mage but I just killed the
hobbits oh that's why they weren't
ranked by bigness cuz they weren't big
oh I'm confused
I don't know what that means uh what is
that guy what is this set asam bow my
killing zombo's here okay cool
I still can't use this if it's
highlighted in red you can't use it but
there's class specific stuff going on
over here whoa hey sumo guy whoa hey
sumo yeah hey one of the great things
about this game is this has a huge
variety of types of enemies I mean even
though that is simplistic I will give it
that this game is very simplistic if
anyone who oh hey whoa hey whoa whoa
whoa Nellie
let some air spare potion here another
skull potion this guy's got too many
friends
I need a crushed oh I got a ring finally
in the tutorial if you actually do the
tutorial you will get some starter gear
doesn't just launch you into the bat
into the badness even though it kind of
did here but that's exactly what
happened here
so I'm guessing again I'm guessing I
don't know everything about this game
that the further you progress into the
forest the heart of the enemies become
and then for
harder the quest become more stuff you
knew yada-yada-yada this game is really
fun
this game is quick easy to pick up easy
to put down a lot of fun to play I like
it so that's all I have to say about it
so I'm gonna leave this one there so if
you want to play it you can get it on
Steam it's totally free to get you can
start playing totally free I'm not
advertising this game in fact I actively
do not recommend you buy anything
because I hate the free-to-play actual
buying microtransaction part of it but
hey if you want something that's fun too
freaked out god what if you want to get
them it's actually fun and you just hit
R to go back into town into the horrible
spam fest that it is but if yous on
something fun that's easy to pick up
that I'm actually gonna be playing a lot
of check it out some steam
totally free so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video it's not that
now